i choose to live by choice not by chance
you can only fight the way you practice
if there isn't discipline how can there
be a true realization of an ideal
1000 days of lessons for discipline 10
000 days of lessons for mastery
[Music]
the path that leads to truth is littered
with the bodies of the ignorant
to win any battle you must fight as if
you are already dead
[Music]
no fear no hesitation no surprise no
doubt
get beyond love and grief exist for the
good of man
[Music]
you must understand that there is more
than one path to the top of the mountain
do nothing which is of no use
[Music]
it may seem difficult at first but
everything is difficult at first
do not fear death
do not regret what you have done
technique by itself is insufficient and
spirit alone is not enough
[Music]
a samurai was essentially a man of
action
[Music]
i worshiped dead men for their strength
forgetting i was strong
sword and mind must be united
self-respect is the fruit of discipline
[Music]
we make war that we may live in peace
the true meaning of the samurai is one
who serves and adheres to the power of
love
everyone feels fear what a samurai or
warrior is is what you do when you feel
fear
a samurai must remain calm at all times
even in the face of danger
one mind any weapon
[Music]
today is victory over yourself of
yesterday tomorrow is your victory over
lesser men
the way of the samurai's founding death
[Music]
having only wisdom and talent is the
lowest tier of usefulness
matters of small concern should be
treated seriously
a samurai will use a toothpick even
though he has not eaten
inside the skin of a dog outside the
height of a tiger
[Music]
there is nothing we should be quite so
grateful for as the last line of the
poem that goes when your own heart asks
single-mindedness is all-powerful
continue to spur a running horse
the basic meaning of etiquette is to be
quick at both the beginning and end and
tranquil in the middle
[Music]
greatness is not the absence of humility
it is the absence of apathy
there will never be peace on earth until
there is peace in us
the warrior knows that their imagination
is not a place to escape but to create
the fool lives to consume all they can
take from the world the wise live to
create a better world
we will never know peace if we lose the
present because we are trapped in the
past and paralyzed by the future
knowledge becomes really such only when
it is assimilated in the mind of the
learner and shows in his character
the sense of honor which cannot bear
being looked down upon as an inferior
power that was the strongest of motives
[Music]
beneath the instinct to fight there
lurks a diviner instinct to love
chivalry is itself the poetry of life
[Music]
dishonor is like a scar on a tree which
time instead of a facing only helps to
enlarge
you are to be proud of your enemy then
the success of your enemy is your
success also
human life has sorrow they who meet most
part he that is born must die
think lightly of yourself and deeply of
the world
[Music]
it is good to face challenges in your
youth he who has never suffered will not
sufficiently temper his character
[Music]
i have a high art i hurt with cruelty
those who would damage me
master the divine techniques of the art
of peace and no enemy will dare to
challenge you
the ultimate warrior leaves no openings
except in his mind
the sword has to be more than a simple
weapon it has to be an answer to life's
questions
master the divine techniques of the art
of peace and no enemy will dare to
challenge you
you might as well stand and fight
because if you run you will only die
tired
a samurai should always be prepared for
death whether his own or someone else's
where life is more terrible than death
it is then the truest valor to dare to
live
[Music]
study hard and all things can be
accomplished give up and you will amount
to nothing
observation and perception are two
separate things the eye that observes is
stronger the eye that perceives is
weaker
engage in combat fully determined to die
and you will be alive wish to survive in
the battle and you will surely meet
death
[Music]
loyalty and devotion lead to bravery
bravery leads to the spirit of
self-sacrifice
the spirit of self-sacrifice creates
trust in the power of love
to practice zen or the martial arts you
must live intensely wholeheartedly
without reserve as if you might die in
the next instant
their attitude towards life was that of
those who always strive to be better and
they saw spirituality as the path to
achieve greatness
[Music]
spiritual service be it of priest or
teacher was not to be repaid in gold or
silver not because it was valueless but
because it was invaluable
the feeling of distress is the root of
benevolence therefore a benevolent man
is ever mindful of those who are
suffering and in distress
never trust a man who tells you all his
troubles but keeps from you all his joys
mental bearing calmness not skill is the
sign of a matured samurai a samurai
therefore should neither be pompous nor
arrogant
the only reason a warrior is alive is to
fight and the only reason a warrior
fights is to win
otherwise why be a warrior it is easier
to count beads
yesterday is but a dream tomorrow is but
a vision
but today well lived makes every
yesterday a dream of happiness and every
tomorrow a vision of hope look well
therefore to this day
i don't get over the wonder of it and
the last samurai was an extreme example
of that
every day when i went to the set i
couldn't believe what i was seeing
[Music]
you